in a somewhat provocative new interview
with Wired Magazine Demis hasabis head
of Google deepmind is quoted as saying
that Gemini which could be released as
soon as this winter will be more capable
than open ai's Chachi PT he reveals that
they are attempting to combine some of
the strengths of alphago type systems
with the amazing language capabilities
of large models before we look into how
that might work here is the context of
the Gemini announcement from Sundar
pichai they are focused on building more
capable systems safely and responsibly
this includes our next Generation
Foundation model Gemini which is still
in training while still early we are
already seeing impressive multimodal
capabilities not seen in Prior models as
the best promises that we also have some
new innovations that are going to be
pretty interesting and I know many
people will dismiss this as all talk but
remember deepmind was behind not just
Alpha go but also Alpha zero which can
play any two-player full information
game from scratch they were also behind
Alpha style which conquered Starcraft 2
with quote long-term planning and let's
remember that for later and most
famously perhaps a Sabbath LED them to
the incredible breakthrough of alpha
fold and Alpha fold 2 which are already
impacting the fight against plastic
pollution and antibiotic resistance so
let's not underestimate deepmind but
back to Gemini we hear from the
information recently that the
multi-modality of Gemini will be helped
in part by training on YouTube videos
and apparently YouTube was also mined by
openai of course that's not just the
text transcripts but also the audio
imagery and probably comments I wonder
if Google deepmind might one day use
YouTube for more than that a few days
ago they released this paper on robocad
which they call a self-improving
foundation agent for robotic
manipulation and the paper says that
with Robocat we demonstrate the ability
to generalize to new tasks and robots
both zero shot as well as through
adaptation using only a hundred to a
thousand examples for the Target task we
also show how a trained model itself can
be used to generate data for subsequent
training iterations thus providing a
basic building block for an autonomous
Improvement Loop notice that part about
using the model itself to generate data
that reminded me of a conversation I had
with one of the authors of the textbooks
are all you need paper Ronan eldan from
Microsoft I'm making a video on their
new Phi 1 model for coding we had a
really great chat and we were discussing
at one point AGI timelines and I said
this when you get Elite math papers with
proofs and Elite scientific research if
you train on much more of those for way
more epochs I don't think we're that far
away from AGI I personally can't see any
barrier within the next five years Ronan
said this as you said I also don't see
any barrier to AGI my intuition is that
there's probably a lot more Improvement
we can do with the data we have and
maybe a little bit more synthetic data
and this is even without starting to
talk about self-improving mechanisms
like Alpha zero where the more you train
models with some verification process
and you generate more data this can be
done in math and other things as we see
here with Robocat so you know there's
just so many directions where we can
still go that I don't think we're going
to hit a ceiling anytime soon can't wait
to show you guys the rest of that paper
and what else I learned from Ronan who
is also by the way the author of the
tiny stories paper but back to Gemini if
you remember the planning bit from
deepmind's earlier systems that reminded
me of something else from Gemini's
introduction Gemini was created from the
ground up to be multi-modal highly
efficient a tool and API Integrations
and built to enable future Innovations
like memory and planning this is echoed
in the article in which hasabis says his
team will combine a language model like
gpt4 with techniques used in alphago
aiming to give the system new
capabilities such as planning or the
ability to solve problems interestingly
this comes just a few weeks after
deepmind's Extreme risks paper which
identified long Horizon planning as a
dangerous capability for example
adapting its plans in the light of
unexpected obstacles or adversaries and
generalizing to novel or new setting for
me this is a bit like when a model can
predict what humans would do in reaction
to its own outputs back to the article
it's interesting though that asabis is
both tasked with accelerating Google's
AI efforts while also managing unknown
and potentially grave risks so what's
his take asaba says the extraordinary
potential benefits of AI such as for
scientific discovery in areas like
health or climate make it imperative
that Humanity does not stop developing
the tech technology he also believes
that mandating a pause is Impractical as
it would be near impossible to enforce
if done correctly it will be the most
beneficial technology for Humanity ever
he says of AI we've got to boldly and
bravely go after those things so how
would alphago become alphago GPT asabis
describe the basic approach behind
alphago in two of his recent talks so
what what's going on here then well
effectively if one thinks of a go tree
as the tree of all possibilities and
imagine each node in this tree is a go
position so what we're basically doing
is guiding the search with the model so
the model is coming up with most
probable moves and therefore guiding the
tree search to be very efficient and
then when it runs out of time of course
then it outputs the best tree that is
found up to that point we've learned
that from data or from simulated data
ideally you have both in many cases so
in games obviously we have this it's
effectively simulated data and then what
you do is you take the model and then
you use that model to guide a search
process According to some objective
function I think this is a general way
to think about a lot of problems I'm not
saying every problem can fit into that I
mean maybe and I'll give you example
from drug discovery which is what we're
trying to do at isomorphic so this is
the tree I showed you earlier finding
the best go move right and you're trying
to find a near optimal or close to
Optimal uh go move and go strategy well
what happens if we just change those
nodes to chemical compounds now let me
know in the comments if that reminded
anyone else of the truth of thoughts
paper in which multiple plans are
sampled and results were exponentially
better on tasks that GT4 finds
impossible like creating workable
crossword or mathematical problems that
require a bit of planning like creating
the greatest integer from a set of four
integers using operations like
multiplying and addition well I think my
theory might have some legs because look
at where many of the authors of this
paper work and just yesterday as I was
researching for this video the tree of
thoughts paper was also cited in this
paper on using language models to prove
mathematical theorems as you can see at
the moment gpt4 doesn't do a great job
but my point in bringing this up was
this they say towards the end of the
paper that another key limitation of
Chaturbate was its inability to search
systematically in a large space remember
that's what alphago is really good at we
frequently found that it stuck to an
unpromising path when the correct
solution could be found by backtracking
Allah tree of thoughts and exploring
alternative paths this behavior is
consistent with the general observation
that llms are weak at search and
planning addressing this weakness is an
active area of research and then they
reference the tree of thoughts paper it
could well be that Gemini let alone
Gemini 2 which is state of the art for
mathematical theorem proving and to be
honest once we can prove theorems we
won't be as far from generating new ones
and in my opinion fusing this alphago
style branching mechanism with a large
language model could work for other
things we've all seen models like gpt4
sometimes give a bad initial answer
picking just the most probable output in
a way that's sometimes called 3D
decoding but methods like smart GPT and
self-consistency demonstrate that the
first initial or most probable output
doesn't always reflect the best that a
model can do and this is just one of the
reasons as I said to Ronan I honestly
think we could see a model hit 100 in
the mmlu in less than five years the
mmlu which I talked about in my smart
GPT video is a famous machine learning
Benchmark testing everything from formal
logic to physics and politics and I know
that predicting 100 performance within
five years is a very bold prediction but
that is my prediction but if those are
the growing capabilities what does
demisasabas think about the implications
of the sheer power of such a model one
of the biggest challenges right now
hasaba says is to determine what the
risks of a more capable AI are likely to
be I think more research why the field
needs to be done very urgently on things
like evaluation tests he says to
determine how capable and controllable
new AI models are he later mentions
giving Academia Early Access to these
Frontier models and they do seem to be
following through on this with deepmind
open Ai and anthropic giving Early
Access to their Foundation models to the
UK AI task force this Foundation model
task force is led by Ian Hogarth who was
actually the author of this the we must
slow down the race to Godlike AI paper
that I did a video on back in April do
check that video out but in the article
Hogarth mentioned a practical plan to
transform these companies into a
cern-like organization and somewhat
unexpectedly this idea was echoed this
week by none other than Satya Nadella
who had earlier called on Google to
quote dance essentially the biggest
unsolved problem is how do you ensure
both at sort of a scientific
understanding level and then the
Practical engineering level that you can
make sure that the AI never goes out of
control and that's where I think there
needs to be a CERN like project where
both the academics along with
corporations and governments all come
together to perhaps solve that alignment
problem and accelerate the solution to
the alignment problem but back to the
article the interview with asabes ended
with this somewhat chilling response to
the question how worried should you be
asaba says that no one really knows for
sure that AI will become a major danger
but he is certain if progress continues
at its current Pace there isn't much
time to develop safeguards I can see the
kind of things we're building into the
Gemini series and we have no reason to
believe that they won't work my own
thoughts on this article are twofold
first that we might not want to
underestimate Google and hasabis and the
adding alphago type systems probably
will work and second based on his
comments I do think there needs to be
more clarity on just how much of Google
deepmind's Workforce is working on these
evaluations and preemptive measures this
article from a few months ago estimates
that there may be less than 100
researchers focused on those areas out
of thousands so is it even five percent
of the total and if not how can we take
too seriously the commitments at any AI
Summit such as the one happening this
autumn in the UK on safety on the other
hand if asabis revealed that half or
more of his Workforce were on the case
then we could be more confident that the
creators of alphago and my fellow
londoners had a good chance of
researching to safety and success as
always thank you so much for watching
and have a wonderful day